The exam.
We have
7 45, I think it starts 7 45 now. Okay. Yeah.
Eight start. Hmm,
Eight o'clock. Actually it
starts. 7 45 will be the briefing. So eight
For that exam?
Huh? Briefing for the exam?
No. No. Just how, how will it be held?
I, I think it's the same, like, they'll tell us
to switch on the mic, uh, camera and, um, all those things.
I don't know whether it's gonna be monitored or what.
It's be loud, God knows.
Uh, okay. Understood.
So, I dunno whether after eight 30 there's gonna be class
also, because the exam is gonna be
from eight to eight 30, right?
So,
Yes. Sorry.
No exam is gonna be from eight to eight 30. I dunno.
After eight 30, there's going to be
Any class or not.
Yeah, exactly. Don't know.
But we don't have the access
that previous links and everything, right?
Yeah, I don't think so. I, I don't know
where those passwords and everything
There is. See, this,
this link is for the class. Okay.
There is one more link created for the exam.
Eight o'clock it opens. So items allowed one, it's there.
See in the, in the element there. Which
Link for you are saying in that, uh,
in LMS you're saying?
Yeah, in LMS, exactly. Yeah. Let me check.
There are two links. One is for eight o'clock exam
and another is for nine o'clock.
Uh, I think it, there not two slot, but,
Uh, okay. Nine o'clock
is also there. Another, okay.
I don't, I think they'll explain us it at 7 45.
They'll explain us. Let's wait.
It's only one slot, but one has a quiz start
Time and other has quiz and time.
Oh, is it? Okay. Oh
8:00 PM Huh?
But nine 30 is the
quiz closes, but it says 30 minutes.
Okay. But a anytime between eight to nine 30 you can log.
That means?
Yes.
Oh, okay.
Looks like we are the most interested to give the exam.
Not like that.
So Anna, you are, uh, you are coming on this 20th. Yeah.
I'll, I'll be there. I'll be there. How about you?
I had, I still have a plan,
but little bit of, uh, maybe I have to drop off.
Oh, okay. Try maximum. It'll be fun. We
Can, yeah. Even I also
wanted, uh, so I can meet everyone there.
Getting, getting back to college.
Many are coming now.
Uh, how many are the total in total confirmed?
Uh, don't know. Probably the, the, this we had, right?
The, somebody had put the vote also. Right. So
Vote was saying something.
17, 18 count, something like that.
I think that would be the counter. Yeah.
21 is there right now. Okay. 21. Probably 30.
30 would be the count. I see.
Mm.
Uh, ug. Brenda, you also also coming?
Uh, no, I'm unable to join. No.
Yeah, no, no, no. From my side.
Okay. Okay.
So do we have exam link where we need to start?
Yeah. Clock. It'll open. It is there,
But link wise, we know which one. Yeah,
Yeah. There is another,
uh, if you see, go to the LS.
Now there isn't another, ah, but is this no, link
It there. If you see, uh,
Just a minute deep learning.
Only 2.1 link.
Or is it? Let me check.
Deep learning quiz opens is there.
Huh? But, uh, after that,
after that, it's showing 2.1 deep learning
and which is going to there, et cetera.
We don't have any link over there.
Uh, please wait. Everyone will join.
I will give their instructions.
Okay. Uh, you go to the deep learning course.
You, yeah, you go to the
Will get the LMS in the, you'll get one quiz
In the deep learning course. Then
Now you go to, you'll see quiz, quiz option.
You'll go to the quiz option. Quiz.
Quiz. Right. Uh,
You have to write the quiz there only.
And, uh, for instruction, camera turn on camera.
That is mandatory for all,
All questions. Oh,
it's not yet activated now. Okay. Understood. Okay.
Yeah, it'll open at eight o'clock.
Eight o'clock. No problem. But it is staying at 30 minutes
and time closes, given us nine 30.
Nine 30. Okay. I'll check. I'll check. Okay.
No, probably once we started,
it'll give a timer of 30
minutes. We only around for 30 minutes.
Actually, lemme clarify that.
Once you started, you will have 30 minutes
to solve 15 questions.
That is why the time limit is set as 30 minutes.
Oh, understood.
So anybody can come till nine o'clock, they can come
and start the quiz.
Right? That means,
Uh, actually we are, we are specifically told
that it should be starting at, uh, eight o'clock only.
Okay. Thank you. Anand.
If you say it'll be, it'll be able to,
then everybody will start at eight 30 after.
No, not like that.
Everyone will write the exam at the same time
because other will share the questions like that. Ah,
Okay. No, no.
Just Writing the exams. No, that's why.
No, no. We are, we are trying to pick up, uh,
college students and try to, don't worry.
Right, right. Maam,
any instructions given,
Uh, instruction I have given?
No, you have to turn on your camera and write your exams.
You have the 30 questions. Sorry. Uh, 15 questions.
And the time duration is 30 minutes.
Simple. You have already written the MLP now.
So once the, uh, exam is over, we can log off. Right?
Uh, we'll wait, if sir will join, uh, sir will take class.
Otherwise you can, uh, log out.
Sure. Okay.
My exam start at sharp. 8:00 PM
Hi, eight o'clock.
I'm waiting for everyone that, uh,
I can give the instruction, otherwise I have to repeat it.
I have to give instruction again.
Uh, your friends will also ask the question. Same, right?
Yeah, no problem. We'll wait, we still have time.
Uh, last time what happened means for other students,
for first time students, uh, MLP,
the server will became very low Last time when I have taken
no, for the cohort two, uh, the server is very low.
If the server is very low, please don't panic. Okay?
We'll extend the time.
I think even when we did it, uh,
last time, it was the same. Uh,
No, not for not for you.
I'm telling about other cohort too.
I got it. I got it. Yeah. Uh,
because some people will get panic.
I'm not, uh, I can't open. That's why they will tell.
No, that's why I'm telling don't be panicked.
We'll give the time.
Sure. We'll, not panic. We are across the state of panic.
Also, don't worry,
No. Last time what
happened? Uh, they'll continuously call us,
uh, to the, uh, LMS team.
They're telling we are, they're calling repeatedly.
Then what should we do? Server will load.
They will, they also can't manage anything. No. That's why
Our, uh, friends will make them panic.
And, and it is a first time also for them. Correct.
So second, seven words will not panic.
We have actually seen more, more, uh, the
good evening.
All good evening, sir. Good evening, sir. Good evening, sir.
Sir, good evening, sir. Good evening, sir. Good evenings.
Good evening, sir. Good evening. Good. Sunil
Is not a joint, sir.
Okay. Okay. We'll wait for,
Uh, hello, sir.
I am vial from this site.
Ah, vial. Please, please, you.
Yes, sir. Today we have quiz at eight to eight 30.
Ah, uh, in LMS they have to write the quiz, sir,
and they have to turn on their camera.
Mm. Yeah. So that's right.
You're for that quiz to happen.
Yes, sir. Mm-hmm.
Sir, uh, when we have a class
after the quiz, sir, uh, I think will join,
maybe some discussion will be there.
Okay, sir? Yeah,
sir, are you talking on mute?
I, I'm just talking to Il. Okay. Okay. Okay, sorry.
So Sarah will join, uh, at eight 30 after the quiz
and discuss about some and other aspects.
Hello? Uh, sir. Now quiz will be starts in two minutes.
Yeah.
To write the quiz, you will get in the LMS
Kindly.
Yes, sir. Switch on your video.
My video is on Zoom. Yeah.
My, uh, la I tried to join on my computer,
but it got stuck, so I'm using my mobile.
Okay. Because one, there, there's one login where, uh,
your video is coming centered off.
Yeah, my lab got stuck, so I just got
Some work. That's
Okay. Okay, no problem,
Sir. I think, uh,
they can start their, uh, quiz now.
It's eight o'clock.
Yeah, please. All the Thank you, sir.
All the Thank you, sir.
Uh, I can't open it. Uh, can somebody help me?
Uh, please open the course. LMS
Refresh. Yeah, refresh
that page. It'll come. Okay.
Otherwise you can log in once again.
Refresh. I think that will be better. Why? To log in.
It should lose some time.
So, uh, please turn on your camera.
Oh, sorry. I forgot.
Please turn on your camera.
Mahe please. Can you turn on the camera?
Mute your mic. Oh, sorry.
Um, please, all of you turn on your cameras.
Some of you're still, uh,
have not turned your cameras on.
Please turn on your camera.
Yeah, there's something issue with my camera.
Uh, I think you need to enable that.
Please quickly, uh, re-log in.
Okay. I,
Hello. Excuse me.
Madam. Madam, can you hear me?
Yes, sir. Yes. Yeah, madam, in question number eight,
actually X three equal to zero point something.
Uh, it looks like the question is incomplete.
Is it 0.0 or something else?
You attend? Other questions? I will check that questions.
Okay. I think maybe Number eight.
Yes. I think maybe they would've
Given float.
Maybe they're given the float notation.
That's why it put a zero dot.
We can take it in that way also. Okay. Yes. Yes.
Turn on your camera.
I
actually, uh, soon as, um, I, uh, interact
with you with the class.
So think it is better if you stay back.
Ma'am, can we at eight 30?
Um, yes, that is also fine. Okay.
But today we will create the class summary. Also.
You have to give the, that also you have to attend.
So please log in at the eight 30.
We'll join at the link given for 7 45. Right in the LMS.
Can you come again?
There is a link given for, uh, 7 45 plus today.
So you'll join at the same link, right?
Same link. Same link.
The same here only.
Oh, it's the same room. Okay. Okay. Sure.
Um, when I'm done, can I switch off my video
or, uh, camera or still monitor?
Yeah, if you finish, you can.
Okay. Thank you.
Excuse me, madam. I completed, can I leave?
But you have to join, uh, class also.
No, already the eight 30 service joiner.
Uh, I have submitted the quiz, so just for a few minutes,
I'm turning off the camera.
Yeah, that's fine,
Ma'am. Which class is
it for? Eight 30. What grisha is
Taking? This is only
same classroom, same class.
Grisha taking. That's what,
Please mute.
Uh, hello ma'am. This is Ganesh.
Uh, I just have one doubt.
Uh, in question four, it seems the option A
and option C, uh, C are both same in question number four.
Uh, you can answer for that one.
We'll, uh, which is correct
because some questions I'm not,
they'll be asked both option also, uh,
is correct in some questions
I'm not able to hear because if
you are saying something, um,
Hello? Can you hear
my voice? Hello?
Yeah, can hear you. Yeah.
Yes, is very able to hear. I Think he's, he's
Unable to, he's unable to hear
For some question.
Some, uh, both the answers, uh, will be correct,
but you have to check and you have to answer.
We will evaluate. Uh,
Sorry ma'am, could you please come again?
It seems some, there was a issue with my sound, uh, audio.
Uh, what, so I'm not able to, uh, hear you properly, so
I have questions.
Okay. There will be, uh, multiple answers are correct. Okay?
Okay. You can select which one is right for you. Okay? Okay.
We'll check and we'll, uh, evaluate, okay? Okay.
Okay. Thank you. Thank you.
Okay, I'm done.
Uh, can you mute your,
Um, the class will start here only, right?
Yes, yes. Please wait several
Time. Okay
Ma'am, can you please tell if possible when the
supplementary result will come out?
You will get in, uh, within two days. Okay.
Uh, in the same, uh, portal, aims portal
where we saw the result,
Uh, I want
to ask the course instructor. I don't know what that,
Okay. Okay, perfect.
It'll be in two days. You're saying
No result. We
have to evaluate that.
I don't know about that more thing.
I will ask the course instructor,
can you put the mail? I will reword that.
Okay, sure, sure. Uh, ma'am, I have doubt
regarding this quiz.
Ma, most of the questions which are being asked,
especially the code snippets
and all, they're all, uh, going to the TensorFlow.
And what we have been taught in the class is PyTorch.
Yeah, that's so For us to correlate with PyTorch and
accordingly, we have to answer.
That's what we have did. I don't know
how much time far it is, correct or wrong.
We got the results also.
So, yeah, so the question was that, uh,
one, one is this question.
The other one is I didn't see the previous, uh,
slides uploaded or even the previous code snippet there.
There's anyone agree that, uh,
previous two classes, slides, and code?
Uh, once again, please, uh, uh, I'll, uh, confirm
that you can please go to the advance.
There is a sir told in the last class also.
We have uploaded that slide also.
You please go and check that in that advance concept.
What sir, uh, taught in the class?
No, everything will be there in the slide.
Yes, ma'am. At least check once again.
It is there. It is there. Ma'am, it is uploaded.
It's there.
No, only in the class. We have told
that TensorFlow is maximum used for the production
and whatever the PY touch has been used
for the development models.
So whatever the class exercise in
what we have practiced was in PyTorch.
So we are not clear about some concepts of 10,
which have been asked in the quiz.
Yeah, good evening to all good.
Good evening. Good evening. Good evening. Good evening.
Sorry for the slide delay.
Actually, I'm out of station, so it took
me some time to connect.
Yeah, so how, how was the quiz,
Sir? I have few
questions.
Yeah, yeah, please tell me,
Uh, do you want me to share my screen
or put it on the chat box?
Oh, uh, you can share the screen, no problem. Yeah.
Okay. One second.
Uh, is my screen visible, sir?
Uh, it's coming started, huh? Now it is visible, yes.
Yes. Okay. Uh, just one question, sir.
Here it says the correct answer is this one. Mm-hmm.
Uh, this, for this one, I need to go and check in detail.
Before that, I have one more question, if you can see here.
Mm-hmm. Uh, the tf dot mat multiplication matrix, ation X,
X comes first and then w
and then we add it to the bias, right?
Mm-hmm. So here, uh, if you see
I have kept it as a mm-hmm.
So it says B,
but then the answers, uh, are contacting
For a single layer network.
Y is it called two WX plus BY?
Which answer snippet is correct. Oh, okay.
Uh, to, to be frank, it shouldn't be a a y here.
Mm, correct? Correct.
Why should, why should not be at the right side, correct?
Yes. We may just make a note of it.
Question number 13, it's it's strong question. Yeah.
So, and so for this question, um, sir, uh,
I think the questions will be jumbled.
Uh, please ask her to take a picture of it.
Mm-hmm. Mm-hmm. Okay. I
Have taken the picture.
Okay. Okay.
Uh, sir, uh, for this question, um, I just wanted
to know why not this one?
Uh, what is it? Which snippet correctly uses DF gradient?
What is that tape type type? It should,
So at first point we were not taught, uh, TensorFlow
and this, uh, course
Correct. And
then PY touch, yeah, PY was discussed.
So, uh, do think, we don't know what gradient tape is,
but then we tried to understand the flow and then, uh, we
Got, so I, I got all the,
I got all the code problems wrong, sir.
Actually, Sir, at least this, these type I got. Yeah.
And we did discuss before you joined, sir.
Oh, this is what happened.
When, uh, TA doesn't listen
to the class properly, they only there.
Okay. Okay. Okay.
Tika, these questions are not, uh, see,
TensorFlow was never taught.
Correct. Okay. So any other, so this question Tika,
I have one question from My end.
That's all. Uh, let me stop sharing my screen.
There were, there were two TensorFlow questions actually.
Yeah. Uh,
Sir, I have one quick, uh,
question about one tensor floor problem. Can I share my
Screen? Yeah. Yes, yes, yes,
please, sir. Please share. Okay, sir,
Sir, uh, this one actually I did not understand, sir,
why is the option B incorrect over here?
Like, uh, can you please explain a bit if possible,
Which snippet correctly computes a two layer MLP forward
pass and return output?
Tenor y. Okay, so go ahead and et
W So correct option says option A.
Uh, I understand. What, what, sir? Why is D incorrect?
Is what I want to understand.
Uh, I, I, I'll have to go through it.
Even I have not gone through the questions.
Okay, officer, sir. Hey, Gary
falls in the tensor flow. So we'll try to,
Sir, can you mark, mark this question as well? Yeah,
Don't worry. So
as where the tensor flow,
it's not valid question we'll remove.
Okay, sir? Yeah. Okay. Thank
You. One thing, one
thing, like the question numbers are like
different in mine, the 13 one wash,
That is okay, that is okay.
That is, that's not a, so we shuffle the questions
that's automated.
That is okay. Literally TensorFlow, we did dinky pinky poke,
no idea how to write.
No, no, no, no problem. No problem.
Yeah, see, I understand.
And, uh, we'll simply remove those, uh,
questions from the grading part.
But see, uh, TensorFlow PyTorch,
they are just a framework, okay?
And you have to see the internal operations
and internal operation.
As soon you will see, you will have,
you will get some understanding like mat, mat.
So matrix multiplication, it is that much you have
to understand it's okay at the time of the exam,
you should put your effort to, uh,
still put the correct answer.
I guess you all of you must have done it.
But yes, from the examination point s point of view
as Tensor pro was never discussed in detail.
So we'll remove those questions no
problem. So actually we have done
The same things.
Yeah, we have Done the correlation of papa touch with,
that's, that's not, you're able to correlate,
but some codes were exactly same with minor changes.
So there we got, uh, just like a bouncer,
We not do anything, whatever we thought we did it.
In fact, one of the prob uh,
questions are two answers are right.
I don't know. I just, uh, selected which one,
which one I could take, take the closest one.
Yes, sir. We had one lambda function
and then the normal function, sir.
Okay. Okay. Please getting, actually,
I have not seen the question this time in detail.
Uh, so anyway, I'll just look into it. No problem.
We'll see that. We'll further, we'll,
one more time we'll discuss that.
So I saw that there are two TensorFlow questions, right?
Uh, that, anyway, we'll remove one more question.
Any other question where we have to, uh, look into that
or any other questions for review?
Uh, there was one perceptron question, sir.
Ah, perceptron question. Okay.
Uh, it was zero point something. Okay? Okay.
We assumed it as zero and then we solved the problem.
I, I, I, at least I particularly solved the problem uhhuh,
but it, for, to me cons, it is co consisting
of an open-ended question.
It can be zero point something as well.
Can, can you please share the screen so
that I can see which question it was?
If you can, uh, I think it is over, sir. It Oh, no problem.
Then we'll look into it. Just a minute. Just a minute.
Let me open it. But it, uh, the result will come in.
I pause you so we can, there is option. Is there, right?
Yeah, yeah. Just a minute. Let me open it up.
Okay. I have one. We can share the screen.
Yes, sir. I'll share my screen.
Sir, I think there are three TensorFlow questions.
Seven, 13. Yeah.
Three. Are there three? Okay. Yeah, three.
Okay. Okay.
Yes sir.
This is a question, sir. Ah-huh.
So input X one, X two, X three is given W one. Okay?
Bias is also given Z value.
You have to compute activate step function.
So what you assumed I did not get
answer will be one,
because jet is always greater than greater.
It depends on the activation function ultimately.
So whether it is zero 0.0, you have
where you have considered zero, right?
Yes, sir. Uhhuh, I indeed it won't change the final answer.
Okay? It won't change the final answer. Okay? Okay.
Yeah. Okay.
Anyway, these things, we'll see, we'll see, uh,
and we will update you next in the next class.
What are the questions we have reviewed
and answer precautions, surely.
Any other questions? Suppose you feel that it is need
to review, let me know.
Sure, yes. I'm sharing my screen. We can see ah,
Yes, yes, yes.
So this one, uh, can you explain this, sir?
Like, uh, uh, as number of layers increase, uh, mm-hmm.
Uh, the,
the initial layer would be slower in learning, right?
The gradient would be almost zero, right?
So it should be a right or
So based on this graph,
which are the following is the most likely consequences
during training of this steep network.
Okay? So we have x axis gradient
magnitude, okay?
Gradient is decreasing as the layer increases.
That is what it is saying.
So after six layer the grade in the gradient, we have very
gradual change up to six layer.
There was some steepness in the gradient. Okay?
That is what is the question?
Option is early layers will update significantly slower,
uh, then deeper layers
because they receive smaller gradients.
Uh, that is not correct, right?
Uh, early layer will update.
Early layers means three layer, number one layer,
number two, layer number four, layer up to layer.
Number six, gradients is steep.
So, uh, I mean,
they will not receive the very small gradient.
I mean there the slope will be very high as compared to
after six or eight at around 10.
So early layer will update significantly slower
than deeper layer, because there is, that is wrong.
You understood why way?
Oh, uh, no.
My thinking was like in back propagation, right?
The grad, the gradients, uh, when it goes
through the initial layers will have
almost no going to zero.
So that learning would be no slower.
No, no, I see what you have to do.
See, based on the questions you
have question, you have to go.
Yes. Okay. Okay.
That is, that is the thing you have
to see the question is given to you.
Okay? Uh, and based on the question, you have
to see which option is correct
and is question says that in the layer number 2, 3, 4, up
to six, the gradient, it's steep so that
obviously it'll have some more, I mean, it's good,
good gradient and the update will be higher side rather
than contrast question.
I understand what you've said. Okay?
And, uh, I, I definitely agree with you what you have said,
but the question that is what you have
to always keep in the mind, okay?
The concept here also applies in the same way.
Only thing is the layer numbers are different.
And in that case, questions,
whatever is saying that you have to follow,
Okay? Yeah. Concept
remains same,
but question, you have to keep in the reference.
Yeah.
Okay. Thank you. Okay. Yeah, fine.
Okay. Any other
query from any other questions?
But, uh, one, one good thing is that, uh,
I believe once you have gone through these questions,
now you have some confidence that whatever you have learned
so far that you have seen in the questions, some questions,
conceptual level questions and all,
and you would absorbed it also.
Okay? So that will give you a little bit confidence, right?
And that you have to carry, you have to keep on, uh, just,
uh, uh, practice, keep on practice these concepts.
Once these concepts up to this concept
and one few more classes, maybe one
or two classes, I'll show you some title code.
Uh, uh, that's all after that.
When once we enter into
that some deep neural network like CNNR, N-N-L-S-T-M
or even transformer, I mean there, uh,
fundamentals will not change much.
That is what I would like to say.
There are only the architecture wise,
you will see there is just some change,
but ultimately there will be a back propagation.
And if you know how it works now,
and that is going to be same
for almost all the architecture,
what you are going to study.
So up to this point and one
or two more class, whatever you are going to study
that you have to keep everything in the mind
that will set the fundamental for the degrading.
Okay? So, uh, uh, this, uh, questions that were there
for TensorFlow, similarly with, uh, using PyTorch,
can you uh, give us some example core snippets so
that we can work with it and get to know, like just
for practicing?
Okay, Tika, we'll set some 10, 15 questions. Sure.
By coming, we just, for your practice,
we'll upload in the LMS you can do
that practice by yourself.
That'd be great. Thank you, sir. Okay. Okay. Okay.
That will do. Alright, so anyway,
we have 10, 15 minutes time, 15, 20 minutes.
So what I will do is I will
present my screen.
Okay,
Sunil, sir, uh, if you don't mind, can you just, uh,
we don't, we have not got any update on the campus
visit, uh, program.
So, uh, is it possible to somehow let us know to want
to contact because we are clueless right now.
We not get got any kind
of communication about the agenda, is it?
So, because today we have received one mail from ris, sir,
and it is not for me, it is for the entire faculty
of triple it that we are pleased to invite you
to actively participate in the campus Emerson program
or for them taking data science
and artificial intelligence on 2020 eighth
and 21st December, 2025.
And we have got the agenda also.
You people have not got No, sir. Oh my God.
What are the timings?
Yeah, on each day, what time on Sunday?
What time it five finishes.
That is what is important because we need
to plan our travel back, right, sir?
Okay. Uh, so I'm not projecting on the screen.
I don't know what change will happen,
but I'll tell you what I have received.
Sure, sir. So day one,
it'll start at nine 30 to 9 45.
Registration 9 45 to to 10 opening remarks.
Then director survey address around 10, 10 30,
break networking.
11, 11 30 about institute academic programs,
okay, that I have to present.
And then 1130 to 1245, professor K Raja from,
uh, ent, uh, give the address, then lunch break,
then we have talk.
This is the talk number three. Okay?
That is mainframes to AI isn't,
and that will be delivered by Mr.
Haran, principle solution architect, CTO, center
of excellent ndl.
Okay, so then 3, 4, 3 15 to four 15 discussion
with the mentors faculty.
Then three break, then campus two for half an hour.
After five o'clock, you will take rest for some time.
Eight to 9:00 PM bank at dinner. That is what we have.
It is written here in day two.
Again, nine o'clock, it'll start nine to 10 15.
Entrepreneurship in deep tech.
That will be the talk 10
to 11 interaction related to the course.
11 to 1115 T break 11, 15 to 1230 feedback.
Atory 1230 to 1:00 PM lunch break. That's all.
After lunch means 1230 to one is a lunch break,
and after that you're free to move means after one o'clock.
After that there is nothing scheduled in the agenda.
But, uh, as you have not received it,
don't consider it final.
Maybe you will get the final one from the geister,
but as per what I have received up to one o'clock in the,
on, on 21st, that is what we are engaging you then you are
free to book your travel back then.
Yeah, sir. Uh, uh, any area of how much, uh,
how long it'll take from Darbar Station
to our institute to travel.
Oh, I, I have full idea
because I live in, so, so I think it'll take,
uh, from Harvard Station.
You're, uh, coming or from Hubli? There are two stations.
Dar Dhar, I'll be coming. Uh, okay.
So it'll take hardly 15 to 20 minutes. That's it. Okay.
No, because uh, if I book my two 30 train, I should be able
to go back to the station by this on Sunday afternoon.
Oh, okay, okay. Okay.
Two 30 train is from Har, which train it is.
Yeah, Darba, which train? It is two 30, sorry, sorry.
Uh, from Hubli.
Ah, that's what, 2 33 SDI from Holi, I guess, right? Yeah.
Hubli Hubli. Correct. I know that
because, so two 30, then you must, so
Hubli is little far from the college.
You have to at least leave one and a half hour early.
Oh my, okay. One hour at least
because it's not, uh, I mean four kilometer main road
and then from there, 15, 20, 20 kilometer cities from
uh, almost college.
So I mean, safe site one
and a half hour before you should leave.
It's better. I take a light range.
It's okay, I'll take it from there, but it's better Uhhuh.
That is better. Uh, I, I guess that is better.
But anyway, you will be, uh, booking the,
see there is no Oola Uber here.
Okay. That is one, one more problem
that is there in Harvard Oakley there is no allowable.
So just, uh, you can, you can book that
and uh, uh, what is the timing?
12 to 1:00 PM lunch break. I think that is not a problem.
Still. You can catch it, I think. No problem.
Yeah, you can book. Thanks
Sir. How far is the airport?
Airport from the backside?
It is, it just take 15 to 20 minutes from highway side.
So far in the sense it'll be
around 10 kilometers. That's all,
Sir. So outside
campus, we can, since you're saying there's no,
or can we get some alternative cab?
I think auto is the only other, other alternative.
So sir, there are auto outside campus, right?
Sometime it is there sometime it is not there,
but from the main road it is.
Usually you will get the auto, uh,
I think there should be something, uh,
they should arrange Garris, sir, if there is some urgent,
you have to leave at one or one 30,
but just keep some, some buffer, right?
I would say rather than rushing, uh, that is
what my, my say would be.
But wait for the Garris instruction.
He's the one who is managing all these things. Okay,
Sir. And in the
Saturday morning, it's uh, start from 9:00 AM So,
uh, suppose from our hotel,
we can get automobile, the campus, right?
Yes. Yes. That you will get it. That you'll get.
Okay. Okay. So auto goes still the campus then.
Ah, yeah. That is not a problem.
Uh, coming is not while going.
If you get the auto
that sometimes getting the auto in the campus gate is,
is a little difficult.
I have seen otherwise coming is not a problem going.
Uh, that is the only issue.
So if you can take the, uh, uh, I see that,
that's why while going, you just keep some buffer.
That is what I would suggest. Okay.
Uh, if I may Yeah, please, please.
Still actually, I had, uh, planned, uh, everything, uh,
in with respect to this event actually.
So I had booked the, the front tenant to train,
but uh, I have an emergency personal work, which I have
to go to Avi on Saturday.
Mm-hmm. So I cannot be attending the Saturdays evening.
So is it fine if I get back and attend the Sundays evening?
Yeah, yeah, that is, see if something is very urgent
and you have to go, you please go.
No problem. I believe so.
'cause I had directly booked for,
but, uh, I recently know that, uh, this work is actually,
so I need kindly inform, uh, uh, ris,
sir, once you will get the mail.
Yeah. Okay. That's all. Nothing else, okay. Okay.
And then, so during this time there,
there is some registration.
I mean, that's why you ly inform him so
that there should be Yeah, which can be taken care.
Yeah. So,
so this time there will be no online classes at the time
for this two days, this will be Saturday, Sunday, right?
Yeah. Saturdays solo classes for, uh,
now looks like there is no class.
Last time I said that there will be class,
but I was also not aware.
Looks like there is no class.
Probably not class not coming there getting a leave.
No, not. Okay.
I think it looks like there is no class in these two days.
Yeah,
Those are going our, uh, pleasure to see the campus.
No, we are missing that.
You should also come correct why you are not coming. It's
Not possible, sir.
Where, where you stay. Hi.
Well then it's not so far, I mean just
No family and all.
I cannot, my son came for the holidays now semester break.
So hardly he comes, he stays in hostel.
You could have taken him is like a holiday.
You're also going your college? Mm-hmm.
No sir. It's a working day for me in college. That
Be brilliant actually, sir.
Actually, uh, I have already once,
but this will again happen after second semester, right?
I believe so. Uh, I believe so,
but I don't know actually what is the plan?
Yeah, okay.
So, uh, it'll be good if it happens
after the second semester again.
Okay? I mean, uh, anyway, some of you are coming
kindly give that feedback.
So our organizers, whoever they, they will,
they will be ready for the next time as well.
So anyway, we are here itself.
We are not going anywhere else.
It's good that if you get the, give that feedback that, uh,
after second semester it should be there.
Just the second. So, uh,
here, uh,
settle study.
Okay? Anyway, we don't have much time.
I'll just brief that what we are going
to do in the next class,
and then we'll continue in the next class.
Uh, so, uh, my next plan is that,
uh, so far you have seen that PyTorch, we have started
and we were doing most of the thing from the scratch.
In the next one
or two class, we are going to make most of the use
of PyTorch modules for many majority of the things like, uh,
building the neural networks model.
Then we are going to use the
Pythons neural network module called NN module.
Okay? And just, just to give you, uh,
that when you will start this NN module,
we will be using a little bit
of the object oriented programming concept.
Little bit. It is not very much in detail,
but we'll use a little bit
of object oriented programming concept
where we'll have the class
and we'll, we will be making the, uh, object of that
and, uh, we'll, we'll be seeing that there,
there are some signatures in the Python
object oriented programming.
So, uh, there is a concept of constructor
that we are going to utilize.
So suppose you are not familiar about it, some
of you are not familiar about it.
So before the next class will happen, kindly see that
what is object oriented programming in Python, okay?
And what are the ways? And it's, it's very simple.
It's not, uh, I mean 15, 20 minutes,
one video, half an hour, one video.
If you will see in the YouTube, you will get the,
get the understanding of what is this OOP, okay?
So, uh, that is just a prerequisite.
Otherwise, anyway, I'll explain you.
But if you will have that understanding, uh, by yourself,
then you will get the concept from the
PyTorch neural network module quickly.
I mean, it'll not be a problem, okay?
Otherwise, those signatures
and those, those, uh, uh, like variables names, may, may,
uh, I mean, they may disturb you a little bit for first,
for some time, unless you're not
familiar about all those things.
Okay? So that is one thing.
What I want you to see
before the next class we'll meet, I mean, on Saturday, okay?
We have still four to five days, half an hour, see any video
for that matter, object to internet
programming in Python, okay?
And see, see some video. That's all. Okay.
So we'll quickly start with an NN module where we'll see
that how to build the neural network layer
by layer, uh, right?
And we'll not write this WX plus B again
and again for every layer, okay?
That we are not going to do.
So, uh, uh, uh, there we will make layer
by layer sequential models in, in,
and, uh, we don't have to write everything from the scratch.
We will be utilizing this, uh, for forward pass,
the neural net, uh, module for backward pass.
Anyway, we have started using this backward,
or wait, wait, uh,
application will be using this optimizers,
something called ba uh, optimizers.
That also will be i'll, I'll explain you that,
that you don't have to worry if you have not seen earlier.
So that I'll explain you.
So those things will quickly shift into some of the, uh,
built in tools or, uh, uh, classes.
What is available with the s
because now we are going to build slowly little
deep networks, maybe three layers,
four layers in every layer.
10, 10 neurons, 20, 20 neurons.
Now, it is very difficult to write everything from the
scratch, okay?
So, uh, we, we are going to start that quickly
and in the, uh, any question?
Yes, sir? I have one question, sir.
Uh, sir, uh, actually, uh,
the GPU, how it can process more information.
So that part is still very difficult to comprehensive maybe.
Okay? Okay. I, I, I'll maybe I'll, I'll cover that one.
Maybe in the coming classes sometime I'll cover with respect
to PyTorch because PyTorch utilizes GPU very efficiently.
Okay? So maybe that part I'll cover sometime that why, uh,
how, how the GPU is being, uh, U utilized
and why it makes the processing so fast,
how the work distributions happens with the GPU and all.
So that, that, we'll see that. Okay, I'll keep that in mind.
We'll cover that. Yes, sir. Thanks sir. Okay. Okay.
Um, sir, one more follow up question.
Uh, yes, on the GPU, so we have the latest, uh, laptops, uh,
especially these AM MDs coming with the N Ps, right?
Yeah. So we can that also be leveraged by this, uh, arch
or only GPU to leverage.
Uh, I see. And PO I guess it can be leveraged.
This, this PyTorch can can use C,
it's a neural processing unit
and PO that is what that Nvidia, I guess they have released.
So I guess that, I mean, they, they compatible with
that one, I guess so, yeah.
Thank you, sir. I, I have, I have not used,
but I believe that these are some
of the basic things which they will not upgrade
by themselves, then it is very difficult
to sustain in the market.
So I don't think that, because I have not heard anywhere
that, okay, the PY is not compatible for, uh,
say the TPU Tensor Processing Unit
or NPU neural processing unit.
So I have not heard, so I think it is compatible.
So you please try it and you'll get to know. Yeah,
Thank you sir. Yeah,
yeah. Okay.
So then, uh, what we'll do is, uh,
in the next class we will completely go
with the pythons mode
and we'll try to build one neural network
and we'll try to see all these things, okay?
In fact, I was building another slide, uh, in instead
of this where,
yeah, this one.
Uh, I, because these are some of the questions you
were asking in the previous some classes, uh,
and I thought that if with the s because theory is fine,
but now, uh, some of you're asking, okay, how many number
of hidden layers should be, how many numbers
of neurons per layer?
What should be the activation function, uh, how
to set the learning rate, what is the optimizers?
How to, what will happen if you change the best sides?
Epoch scheduling, if we can do what is early stopping, okay,
so these are some of the concept we use for fine tuning
of the neural network hyper parameters.
So these are all called as the hyper
parameters of the neural networks.
So we will see everything in the pipe torch in the,
with the hands-on rather than going into the
theory mode much.
So that is what I have planned next.
And next we'll see that,
that whatever gradient vanishing gradient problem we have
seen so far how to solve that problem.
So, uh, we have activation choices, which we had talked
that day also, that if there is a sigmoid activation
function, if it will be there in the head
and layer, then the vanishing vanishing gradient problem
will be, uh, there, there is very high chance
of getting the vanishing gradient problem, right?
So if you change that, uh, uh, like say that sig I
to relu in the internal head
and layer, then what will the impact Now
that also will see in the pipe touch
weight initialization some of the tricks.
We'll see that there are some methods
for the weight initialization.
We'll see that one, something called like
batch normalization.
Okay? Very important. In fact,
in the transformer architecture, uh,
they have proposed equivalent to the batch,
normal normalization called as layer normalization,
layer normalization, batch normalization.
In, in some aspect they're similar,
but they're different as well.
So what is this batch normalization,
why it is very important in the vanishing gradient problem
or exploding gradient problem to address that.
That also we'll see,
and in the case of exploding gradient problem is a concept
top gradient clipping.
So all these things I want to show with the PyTorch,
and that is what I have the next plan.
So I thought I'll, uh, discuss it a little,
but then we don't have much time, we'll not start it,
but I'll just, uh, so if suppose you don't have enough data,
then there is a concept of transfer learning
or unsupervised pre-training, okay?
What is that? That we are, we will understand a little bit
if suppose your, uh, training is slow,
then we have a concept of optimizers that that,
that will see learning rate scheduler that also we are going
to see, okay?
And then we have a concept.
If we have a over fitting problem, which is very
like obvious with any machine learning model, right?
Then we have some regularization technique, L one, L two,
or dropout, which is very famous, right?
In the neural network dropout layer.
When we add in between, so,
or take up data augmentation, all these things,
what I planned next to, uh, uh, to, to show you with the,
to give you a little bit of conceptual understanding
and then see in the pies that okay,
how these things are working
and how much it'll, how, how it'll make the impact in the,
uh, performance of a neural network.
Okay? So that is the next plan I have.
But, uh, rather than starting today,
we'll see that in the next class.
So only, only, uh,
assignment is can we have a little bit understanding
of object oriented, uh, programming, uh, of in the Python
that how the classes are defined, what is a constructor?
Okay? Uh, so little bit of signatures, okay?
With half an hour or one hour video,
you will have some understanding of that, come with that,
and then I guess you will understand all
these concept quite easily.
Okay? So please let me know if you have any other query
for today, sir.
Otherwise, will there be any class notes for this
to be done for today?
Because I don't think we have discussed much also.
Yeah, we have not discussed anything.
So I guess, uh, I guess, uh, we,
we should not have any class.
So, uh, it is enabled. It is already enabled, yes, sir.
Okay. Then write something, whatever you understand,
it'll be okay.
Anyway, we have discussed a little bit.
Whatever we have discussed, just write it. No problem.
We have discussed about TensorFlow is not, uh, taught,
but it is given in the question, write it, no problem.
Okay. It's an why to cancel it also, right?
That, uh, it's 15 minutes from station to our Yeah,
definitely, definitely, definitely.
So class, class learning. So everything is a learning.
Yeah, no problem.
For our, I I did not get to, your voice is available, uh,
during, yeah, yeah, I'll be available.
I'll be available. I'll, yes.
Is that Yeah, yeah, please, please, please come.
Please come. Yeah. Do we cover any vector databases?
Not in this course. Vector databases will be in the next
course where will start with the LLM
and uh, that's where this, uh, little bit of rag will come,
will try, will, will have that way.
So that will, that is there in your ec co uh, mtech, uh,
curriculum, but not in deep learning course.
Yeah. Okay, sir. Okay, thank you. Yes, yes.
We, we discussing regarding tensor rt, uh,
what is tensor rt, sir?
Uh, it's, uh, another, uh, framework just like, uh,
TensorFlow for, uh, improving the inference field.
So whenever we are processing any image
or video processing,
so basically in surveillance based projects, uh,
for processing the CCT Vs.
So to improve the inference speeds, uh, they usually use 10.
Oh, so, so these, uh, detection models,
which we have yellow, so, uh, they would be converting that,
uh, pre-train model to this 10 based engines.
Oh. So I don't know whether we have planned it or not. Okay.
Because I was, I'm not much aware
because I don't work much with the image data.
Okay. So I have may I mostly work with the NLP,
so whatever happens with the text that I'm,
I'm aware much rather than vision or image,
but we'll see that if it is required.
And, uh, if it is coming with the, uh, with the,
this deep learning course, uh, then, then we'll start to see
that if we can cover or we can give you some reference
material where you can learn by yourself.
Okay, I'll see that. Okay. Okay. Okay,
Sir, any idea about when our march
for this last semester will be released?
Uh, mark sheet, uh, miss grade, grade card, right?
That which course, what grade you have got, correct? Yeah.
Yes. Uh, okay. Hmm.
Uh, but I have not talked on that, uh, for that matter,
but I'll just look into it.
Maybe I'll update you. Sure, yeah.
Okay, then. So any, yeah. Yeah.
So any idea when the supplementary results will be
released for the supplement, uh, for first semester?
Oh, I, I am not, not sure about that.
I'll have to again, uh, go back
to the Isha, what is the status.
Okay. Focus. Yes, yes.
One request, sir. So some of the PPS
of the earlier sessions, uh, the long P PT on the,
and this one back propagation, uh, illustration, right?
Those are not available in LMS.
Can someone upload that, sir?
Oh, PPTs are all PPTs that are available, right? But
Even that, the epoch batch, every,
all the differences even I could not see that
I did. So. No,
Sir. Everything is
uploaded, sir.
Everything uploaded, Uh, batch, uh,
that also the upload, sir,
last time I have given the folder name is,
uh, advanced concept.
Oh, okay, okay. Okay. Take it. We'll switch.
We'll see that. Okay. I will see the LMS once again. Thanks.
Whatever is left, we'll upload it. Okay? Yeah. Uh, fine.
Okay. Let us meet on, uh, Saturday then.
Okay. Thank you, sir.
Thank you, sir. Sir.